what do you make a Bob Lazar story in
terms of possession of aircraft do you
believe him I don't believe in the Bob
Lazar story to be quite honest I mean
Jeremy Corbell has done a great job
interviewing him and uh has done some
you know beautiful uh documentaries
um I just don't I
I don't know how to interpret it and
um you know and again this some of the
people who
fraternize with think it's all rubbish
uh yeah but he maybe he's right but I
don't know I mean the problem is
and um
this is a little bit different about how
I approached the whole area than a lot
of others
I'm less interested in going over old
paperwork
and all these old histories of who said
what you know the whole He Said She Said
of the history of of UFOs
I'm a scientist
I worked on the brain
area because it's something I can
collect data on I can go back to the
same individual collect their MRI again
and redo it I can hand that MRI to
somebody else they can analyze it I can
get materials I can analyze them I can
get some of these skeletons I won't
touch any skeletons ever again but I can
analyze it and somebody else can
reproduce the data yeah I mean that's
what I'm good at and so you know I'm I I
I'm not going to go into the whole I'm
not a historian yeah that's true but
there's a human side to it
I want sometimes I think with these
because again anomalous rare events some
of the data is inextricably connected to
humans the observations right
um I mean I hope in the future
you know that that sensory data will not
be polluted by human subjectivity but
you know that's still that's still
powerful data even direct observations
like if you talk about about pilots and
so it's an interesting question to me
whether barbazar is telling the truth
whether he believes he's telling the
truth too and what also what impacts his
story and stories like his have on the
willingness of governments to be
transparent and so on so you know you
have to credit his story
for captivating the imagination of
people and that getting the conversation
going he's maintained his story for all
these years with little to no change
that I'm aware of so
um but there's so many other people who
are let's say experts in that story
um their gut you know you accumulate us
a set of sort of uh circumstantial
evidence where your gut will say that
somebody is uh not telling the truth
yeah